the very first time I left the ground in
a general plane I knew it was over my
life was done it's all going to be about
two aeroplanes it was not just because I
was in the air but I was depending upon
myself so my safety was in my own hand
it was one of the most exhilarating
sensations that I've ever received in my
life my name is George Jacob and I'm
known as gyro Jake I build gyroplanes
from scratch what a gyroplane is
basically a hybrid airplane helicopter
but it's neither of the two nominees
aeroplane I would say I'd built close to
20 I lost count around 15 a few years
back I imagined what I want and what
components should fit together then I
machine out and weld up the parts that
are necessary to get the job completed
sometimes you can take two months
sometimes you can taking you there's
times I look at it I go man I did that
and it works and I want to fly it thing
is that when I first started it was a
pretty small clique in Florida and so we
get together on the weekends
today the gyro community is probably
increased by a hundredfold
especially with the new revolution of
the factory built arrows to
do-it-yourself builders are kind of like
the dinosaurs they're on their way to
being extinct there aren't many people
that spend most of the free time
building a gyroplane one after the other
after the other there's no incentive
like money that compels me to do this
it's just because this is my pleasure
this is my joy this is my passion
[Music]
you